so the big announcement in astronomy
over the last few weeks is a discovery
of a huge new ring around Saturn
absolutely enormous far bigger than the
existing rings I mean it's kind of
interesting and there's a theory as to
where it comes from that it's probably
that's one of the one of the moons of
Saturn's shares the same orbit as this
enormous ring moon called Phoebe and
it's thought probably this new ring is
material that was ejected from Phoebe
when something smashed into Phoebe and
in fact if you just add up the total
amount of stuff that has to be in this
ring to give you some idea of how
diffuse of it it is even though it's
spread out over this enormous region of
space it's actually only about sort of
one craters worth of dust one craters
worth of bits and pieces so it's
probably something smashed into Phoebe
through a dug out a new crater and the
material was ejected in that crater is
now forming this ring
Saturn's entire ring and satellite
system is probably one of the most
interesting parts of the solar system
there's there's lots of stuff going on
out there
Saturn's got over 60 moons or little
moonlets as well as this big large ring
system and if you were to actually go
and look at the Rings in detail you'd
find that they're not they're certainly
not a solid object they're made up of
lots and lots of little particles
ranging from microscopic little dust
particles up to big Boulder sized chunks
of rock and mostly ice really and they
line up in a really flat circle around
the planet so to scale they actually are
thin as a piece of paper so it's
amazingly thin even though they go very
very far away from the planet and the
Rings change their angle to us so
sometimes we see the Rings is this big
brilliant circle around the planet and
sometimes they're actually angled flat
as they just were at the beginning of
this year so sometimes you can't see it
which confused Galileo to no end when he
first found these 400 years ago one of
the things he could never quite figure
out was Saturn because he said his
telescope was so crude and so simple
that you really couldn't get a decent
picture of Saturn with it and so he
concluded that Saturn probably had ears
he could see these bits sticking out the
side and he described them as ears it
was only much later that it was realized
that it's a complete ring system around
it you've sure got it if you show
Galileo the pictures you get you know he
put the hubble space telescope at Saturn
the amazing pictures you get with it he
will be truly astounded the really
really spectacular images of Saturn have
come from the hugely successful Cassini
mission so this one's one of my
favorites so what you're looking at is
just a portion of Saturn's ring system
and you can start to see really how thin
this ring system is and it's curving
around here but what's neat about this
picture in my mind is that in one
snapshot you get a view of some of the
other interesting parts of the Saturn
ring system so one is this tiny little
moon here can't remember the name of it
and but you can see that it's really
quite small it's really quite irregular
but behind is the glory of Saturn's moon
system which is tightened and Titan is
again one of the most interest
parts of the solar system you see that
this picture here is hazy and it's hazy
because Titan actually has an atmosphere
and not just a little thin atmosphere a
real proper thick atmosphere made mostly
out of nitrogen and other gases like
that so it makes it one of the prime
spots in the solar system where we'd
love to go and look for signs of really
primitive life so hitching a ride on
Cassini right at the beginning of the
missions was a separate probe called
Huygens that probe was launched into the
atmosphere sent down information as it
streamed down through the atmosphere and
was designed to actually land with a
thud on the surface of Titan and send
back information about what it landed in
so it was completely unclear whether it
would land in an ocean and float around
or whether it would land on solid ground
it turns out it landed on something I
think was best described as creme brulee
so something a bit but with a bit of
give in it but with a bit of a crust as
well so one thing about Saturn is that
it's not very dense it's the least dense
planet in the entire solar system
in fact it's less dense than water so if
we could find a body of water as big as
we needed to plop Saturn right in it's a
turd would actually float in that water
Saturn also has my favorite moon which
is Mimas and I like it because it's
rocky it's got a lot of craters on it
but there's one huge crater that's about
1/3 of the diameter and it looks like
the Death Star it's the Death Star moon
so this one is even even better this is
my my real favorite picture Saturn and
again this is sent back from the Cassini
probe and what you're seeing is Saturn
in eclipse
so Cassini is actually sitting behind
Saturn and the Sun is on the other side
so just as if on earth sometimes the
moon gets in in front of us between us
and the Sun and we get an eclipse that's
what you're seeing here
Saturn is eclipsing the Sun so you're
seeing it backlit so the Rings are being
backlit some of that light is scattering
off so we do actually see the dark side
of Saturn
through scattered light and you see this
wonderful wonderful effect of the ring
system and you see how layered it is and
how it extends out and even to really
really fuzzy rings much further out but
the very best part of this picture in my
mind gives us a little perspective is
this little spot here and it's not it's
not a spot on my computer screen if we
zoom in a little further you see it here
you see it's actually a little round
blob and that's the earth that's the
earth seen from billions of miles away
and again really just shows us what a
tiny little insignificant spot we are in
the universe but how lucky we are to be
able to send out these probes and send
back information like this